Sometimes a container on a pod
can be up and running but
the application inside of
the container might be malfunctioning.
For instance if your
code was deadlocked.
Kubernetes has built in support to make
sure that your application is running
correctly with user implemented
application health and readiness checks.
Readiness probes indicate when
a pod is ready to serve traffic.
If a readiness check fails then the
container will be marked as not ready
and will be removed from
any load balancers.
Liveness probes indicate
a container is alive.
If aliveness probe fails multiple times,
then the container will be restarted.
Let's see a visual example
of this in action.
In our example,
we have a pod with a container at B1 and
Kubernetes daemon called a Kubelet.
Since the Kubelet is responsible for
making sure that a pod is healthy,
it's going to perform the live check.
Hey, app v1, you alive?
In this example for whatever reason.
Our container is dead and that's denoted
by the outline in the red color.
So it's going to respond, nope.
Since this is the case, the Kubelet
will restart our container and
then it will perform
the check again as necessary.
Hey, app v1.
You alive?
And this time everything is good.
App v1 will say, yeah.
That was just a quick overview of
pod monitoring and health checking.